je vous propose à présent de partir à la
rencontre de Vincent Armand un jeune
conducteur de train passionné par son
métier il travaille à la SNCF depuis
deux ans et nous partage son quotidien
bon bagage et Rodolphe
c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans c'est dur
[Musique]
bonjour donc je m'appelle Vincent Armand
j'ai 23 ans je suis conducteur de train
à la SNCF au TER depuis maintenant 2 ans
[Musique]
ouais ça va donc j'ai passé un BAC PRO
mécanique et dessin industriel à Dijon
ensuite le ferrovert m'a toujours attiré
donc du coup j'ai été contrôleur pendant
trois ans et donc de là j'ai découvert
le métier de la conduite qui m'a donné
envie et donc j'ai postu la SNCF pour
pour faire ce métier pour ceux qui me
plaît le plus c'est d'être autonome et
de sentir utile au quotidien des
personnes
le fait de voyager de voir du monde de
voir du paysage de pas avoir de routine
dans le boulot c'est ça qui m'a tiré et
d'avoir un bureau finalement mobile
c'est beaucoup d'aspects techniques et
voilà faut pas oublier que la chose
numéro 1 c'est la sécurité pour les
voyageurs je suis des conducteurs de
train et sur l'aspect certification on
s'assure que le conducteur applique bien
ses procédures les connaissent sa
réglementation
[Musique]
vu qu'on est tout seul en cabine on est
on a assez la solitude des fois peut
être pesante donc des fois les les
adultes ou les enfants qui nous font
coco au bord des des voies ouais ça fait
plaisir ou quand des personnes nous
disent bonjour ou merci tout simplement
ça c'est ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
étape me remet dans le mal je te donne
très impliqué et très disponible très
bonne agent investi
au début c'est pas facile salut mais
avec avec
l'ancienneté on prend le on prend le
rythme finalement et donc c'est pour ça
que le repos hyper important est-ce que
d'être toujours en décalage c'est
fatiguant
donc on voit que lundi je prends 14h27
le 13 est un découpé à Lyon moi pour le
rythme j'ai déjà le rythme de nuit
depuis mes 18 ans donc voilà une bonne
hygiène de vie j'essaye de manger à
régulière mais c'est pas facile parce
qu'on voit là je fais 10 heures du matin
à 21h donc on mange sur le pouce des
fois en cabine de conduite alors au
début quand on commence et qu'on a voilà
quand on est jeune comme moi oui la
pression elle est là mais après on se
dit bah gérer si mon examen j'étais fort
et pour donc je vois pas pourquoi j'y
arriverai pas et donc c'est avec ça en
faisant de manière c'est en pratiquant
en faisant que
qu'après on devient plus à l'aise pour
moi avoir 20 ans 2022 non ce n'est pas
dur juste il faut savoir ce que l'on
faire dans la vie se donner les moyens
parce que si on veut travailler il y a
du travail c'est un métier qui est pas
très connu finalement qui est un peu
méconnu du grand public les amis ne
comprennent pas forcément un métier
qu'on a pas nos samedi soir on n'a pas
le dimanche soir qu'on peut travailler
Noël ou jour de l'an moi dans 20 ans je
me vois où
je me vois encore dans ce métier là
après avoir commencé à évoluera mais
au TER au TGV je ne sais pas voilà je me
dis j'ai bossé dur pour avoir le métier
que je voulais je l'ai vu donc c'est
pour c'est pas pour y rester un an ou
deux c'est pour faire une carrière